hello we are back
live it's only a bit past
7 probably got a good couple hours to
keep coding on
this this is driving me nuts but maybe
we get it running today who
knows let's go through this a little bit
so
it could be time to just start trying to
get it running
actually the observations are not uh not
there yet I
that ooh this OBS buff is not a thing
either
OBS I don't like this
thing next
TS and where do these functions come
from maybe there's a fair bit of extra
work to do do
here so I just forgot these two
functions I
guess torch jit script is
commented going to comment it here as
well
rotate the import Star is just the
cherry on top
here from utils import Okay so [ __ ] this
is their
yous no my guy that's a
scam that's not a the coin's not me I
don't have cryptos I don't have crypto
I no it's not so all of our stuff is
open source but puffer is a startup we
sell service packages to companies the
idea is that if you're doing
reinforcement learning and having a hard
time with it we can
help after all why wouldn't you want to
have the people who are uh building the
highest performance easiest to use most
stable reinforcement learning tools out
there on your
side dude I can I can raise millions of
dollars for my company right right now
if I want to I don't want VC funding
because I don't want the strings
attached to
it puffer intentionally bootstrapped for
that
reason it's not like I hate money I want
puffer to be profitable but uh the
research comes first you know the goal
is to revolutionize reinforcement
learning we're going to make stuff fast
we're make stuff stable we're going to
make stuff easy to use and it's all
happening this year thank
you I mean if you take a look at some of
the stuff that we've done just in the
last six months you'll see it you'll
definitely see
it and we have made so much progress in
just the last six months
I mean we now have stuff that's running
training in a million steps per second
tons of different environments various
complexities and brand new people to
reinforcement learning can write them
that is something that was like so far
out of the realm of existence 6 months
ago it's not even funny
they don't have the full API it looks
like am I wrong here is
this any one
tells okay so Isaac Jim does have a
torch you
tells um
work we'll get rid of all the ones of
these that we don't
need oh my
it's right here did I just miss it where
did K add
it compute humanoid reward compute
humanoid reset
there's more [ __ ] in
here they just they have so much
I mean they just have too much code like
this is a ridiculous reward function
what is
this let's see what's still missing in
here yeah this one
okay if I scroll through
this should be nothing undefined I think
I have to import OS and a couple small
Li
TCH is hoi and then I guess this make
function this make function gets much
easier now because we just do like this
th000
lines we'll be able to cut some of
this for reference the original is over
2,000
so we've uh We've cut the code down a
lot still have a little more to go
I got to go back into the freaking the
base class
again okay it's viewers none so this is
m. viewer
uh right here yes n so it's going to be
n
viewer and why is n not here there
should
yellow okay at least
everything outside self is defined
we're going to have to test this a
bunch let's commit it first
pams I
mean can I not just do
where I could just make them
default it irritates me a little bit to
duplicate but
like control headless
oh yeah JY torch is an Isaac Puck we got
to figure that
tensor okay all I need is wrap tensor
and unwrap tensor from this
dude how is
this RP tenser
second there should be something built
into Isaac for this right did these just
got did these guys just write their own
dumb thing for no
reason hang on
going currently trying to make Isaac Jim
work without being
ridiculous okay this is not Isaac Jim is
not
here this is an external
tensor using the provided gym torch
interop module
here my your work currently studying
CS hey feel free to get involved it's
all open source stuff um you know we
have people that come in with just a
programming background and within a
month or two are implementing a really
awesome
environments you know they're all right
here
I mean most of them are written by
contributors I wrote a few of the more
complex ones nur3 and
MOA doing crypto while I'm on
break you know the uh the token is not
mine um I made an announcement about
that that's just somebody impersonating
me I would generally suggest staying out
of that space
scammers much more fun stuff going on in
AI much much more fun stuff going on in
AI rap tensor imple okay so this is
imported but it's not getting
called wait
let me say so from Isaac Jim
import gym
packages okay so why is it trying to
open from there
okay it's not there so I don't know why
it's
there I mean I'm sure this is not going
to help
but you never know
maybe this has been
solved and indexed by GPT
this search thing is
nice yeah this is
resolved I don't know how this is
supposed to work but whatever
bright
side can't really get
scammed it's really
not I have infinitely many better ways
to make
money than digging into
crypto it sounds appealing but it's not
trust me
Source I have a source folder oh wait
hold on maybe this is the issue where is
there
okay why is the file not
there what up to I'm dealing with
[ __ ] cursed simulation
packages compens I am what I'm doing
right now is for a
client the uh the binding for this is
part of a contract uh but it gets open
sourced in puffer
lib we've got a couple active contracts
at the moment funding puffer uh it's a
small amount but you know it'll grow
we've only been open for business for a
few months the goal is going to be to
get this year to get about five active
contracts which would give us uh
sufficient funding for myself hardware
and uh you know sizable bounties on
various things which will be quite
good but hey it takes time building a
business takes
time we've actually gotten a couple
pretty solid contributors Spencer being
one of them uh people who have just like
come into this space been super
enthusiastic and learned really fast and
built a lot of cool environments now the
open source Community Vib has been
pretty
good and you know I'm starting to have
cool stuff to throw back to people soon
I've got uh there's one upcoming project
that's going to with uh with NYU that
actually I think Spencer either you or
Captain would be great for that comes
with
authorship um so that's pretty cool and
I'm working to generate a few more
opportunities as well getting some
meetings lined
up business side of [ __ ]
yeah so the uh the ideas spener now this
isn't confirmed we're going to chat
about this in a couple of weeks after uh
they finish their conference stuff but
um really the GPU engine is not doing
them any favors we're thinking about
just was doing a straight Port uh as an
ocean EnV of a GPU Drive making it like
20x
faster so then they'd be able to like
base all their research on this way
faster thing integrate puffer neoc carbs
basically pull it into our ecosystem
pull the environment Dev into our
ecosystem
I I just don't have any interest in
interacting with the crypto space
don't there's so much more cool stuff
over
here if you're interested we have like
there's so much more cool stuff over
here
the RL side is starting to get good
enough that like you know we've actually
got a pretty solid proposition for
companies look like I I own like a small
number of ETFs with some Bitcoin and
stuff but that's about as much as I do
and that's like a very small part
that sounds up my alley can you give me
a quick rundown it's a GPU Accel
accelerated driving Sim that's built on
Madrona which is uh a GPU engine
basically a GPU accelerated game engine
that handles some of the physics and
stuff so the idea would either to be
Port it to use either box 2D or
depending on how simple the physics is
maybe just our own
stuff um so we have to replace some of
the physics from adona but other than
that like their source is only a couple
thousand lines I don't think it would be
any longer in C I think it would be way
faster because they handle like variable
numbers of cars and stuff with fix size
tensors with very low density which is
really bad for them um yeah bunch of
stuff I mean I only really have a small
amount of Bitcoin it's like I don't know
it's for me it's not as interesting I'd
rather have like Nvidia and Tesla you
know companies that I care about that I
think are doing good work and that I
think are you know going to
appreciate because they're doing good
work I also have you know
diversification stuff but I don't do
very much I don't day trade I just I
don't even look at them right I just
have some stocks and I just leave them
there for
years I really don't think about them
much
I'm more interested at the moment in
figuring out how to get recurring
revenue for puffer like a few solid
contracts on stuff because that
generates opportunities for you know
other RL PhD students for contributors
generates lots of cool
stuff let me know yeah no I mean I've
been supporting them for a while now and
it's just like we've gotten to a point
where I've optimized the heck out of
their environment and it's become very
clear that it's the engine that's slow
as soon as you take it out of optimal
conditions beat level two very good
solid good
progress going to throw Neo carbs at
that thing pretty soon I
imagine uhuh Investments aren't
Investments aren't the same thing um
these are two very different things like
having Investments That generate Revenue
that's like a startup getting 10 million
funding and then saying that like oh
yeah we've got 500k in Revenue because
it's like you know sitting in an ETF
right that's not how it
works see the goal here here right is to
be solving real is to be using our Tech
to solve real problems in RL for
companies in the process building up our
open- source tools to even be better
suited for various industry problems and
then it builds on itself that's what we
do
and then the more companies right that
want support contracts with
us the more RL devs I get to bring
aboard uh in some capacity as
contractors or otherwise in order to
then be building stuff on puffer and for
clients but a lot of it keep stays open
source that's how we roll and it just
like this is how you very quickly
accelerate reinforcement
learning and they've already started to
see this
working so the model that we have is not
like it's not amazing
for uh it's not amazing for like pure
profit it's profitable potentially but
not amazing for that but it's really
good for getting like good Dev like good
organic Dev
growth plus I've been an open source
forever it's kind of my thing
plg stuff
functioning yeah you should definitely
do that
the heck is there no Source folder in
Isaac
bindings and the dinner C
Spencer
no man you're showing me stuff in the
most [ __ ] space in all of Tech right
now you're showing me like GPT wrapped
like this is literally the most [ __ ]
over hype space in all of Tech right now
why do you feel that
way I mean ask around like for like ask
around people that have been in AI for a
while
like you're calling GPT in a for Loop
you're having it interact with some
databases like this stuff is just going
to get built in by the larger companies
like you're not actually pushing any of
the AI research forward all you're
really doing is you're trying to jump
ahead of open AI by 6 months and cash
out that's all you're doing
here like that that's what these
projects are
doing right they're kind of just trying
to stay ahead of the
curve of the frontier Labs who are busy
working on the core models by wrapping
them and trying to eek a little bit
extra out of
them and like agents is this
ridiculously hot keyword right now even
though the stuff doesn't actually
work it's one of these things where
there's just a Zeitgeist and yeah prints
free money but that doesn't mean you're
really doing anything like sure if
you're smart and you jump if you're
smart and you jump into the currently
Hot Space right if you're just smarter
than the next guy in the rat race you
yeah you're going to be able to cash out
some money but what are you doing with
your
life I'd rather make some I'd rather
make money doing something that's going
to legitimately Advance Science and
Technology that's something I can be
proud
of okay so for some reason this
installed does not
weird do you think you can change the
way people say and Advance the space
what I'm doing now in RL will will be
this RL was this amazing field that was
making super rapid progress up until
about
2019 and it's not like we really got
stuck or anything all that happened is
language models happened and all the
funding moved over to language models so
a lot of the good people moved over to
there but like the tech is good it just
needed some work it hasn't gotten the
level of investment that llms have
gotten
and we're doing that work now and we're
doing it very very
quickly I'm taking advantage of
something else right I've have an area
here of AI that is going to be
tremendously impactful in a large number
of Industries in a way that language
models will not be and very few people
are doing it and it requires a fair bit
of knowledge and experience in the space
which I
have it's it's really not very
interesting to me to jump into the thing
that everybody else is doing because
like again you're kind of just fighting
to be a few months ahead of the next
guy I'd rather do something that's Niche
and out there that you know where really
there's not going to be progress unless
you make there be progress I mean this
is just how I see
things right I don't get up in the
morning to get a few days ahead of the
next guy
how do you
have I'm surprised that's a valid maybe
restream just isn't rendering your
username yeah no I I stream because I
enjoy narrating this type of stuff on
once in a while you know I enjoy
answering stuff on I enjoy answering
questions about puffer I enjoy getting
people excited about RL I enjoy kind of
going through my thought process on
stuff it's all part of
it occasionally I [ __ ] about having to
deal with freaking terrible academic
code but we deal with
it you know we deal with it
I started I feel I'm at the top of the
world but after some time I
stop I don't know quite know what you
mean by
that
original holy that's ridiculous
dude why why do they do
this what
like they put the original Isaac JY
inside of Isaac JY including the
freaking source file that we
need Okay um
is this enough or do I have to re I
might have to recompile I don't know it
depends it might Hot
wait Isaac
gem not quite it's got to
okay so it's not getting copied
over but
Go hip install oh
wait yeah you have to go
here on 3.8
dmall try this
Isaac come
on still no
Isaac oh I
remember yeah I remember
so very weird I think you got to
do install dot doesn't work with Dash e
for some reason yeah there we go now
it's building the
we're going to have to package this
thing up in a container like it is such
a
now it has underscore bindings but it
doesn't
have still doesn't have
SL okay
so package
files collect files Isaac
Jim bindings Linux
collect how about
this does this work
folks currently this is Isaac Jim very
common physics
simulator uh it is a pain to set up and
it has about three generations of PhD
students worth of horrible wrapper code
so we're trying to clean everything up
get it running nicely and very fast with
puffer lib so that we can do all sorts
of things with
it but it is a pain
e I have no idea what happens if we try
to install numpy
1.20 or
1.16 we'll see if puffer lib still
works and that's super
old that's a bug there you can just fix
the
type can I it's in uh I guess I can fix
it in their code we just have a fork or
it's not even a fork because they
uh what is
this hey
K I hope this is helpful I've been
working on this [ __ ] all day
is a pain I've got it down it's going to
be about half the length it was before
though it looks
like they really had a bunch of
redundant and bad
code isolated gym torch
CDM
did you change some
stuff or is it just that one thing
should I go grab
it cuz I noticed that
um some of these
repos they have like their own gym torch
instead of the Isaac one which I assume
is because of the Isaac setup
error thanks for explaining what we're
doing so once we clean the mess up what
kinds of things I mean Isaac Tim is a
general purpose physics simulator right
it does humanoids it does like ant it
does tons of different things it's
pretty fast um it's a high fidelity
simulator there are like successors to
it but actually a lot of people still
use this one cuz the successors are
pretty
finicky um I mean generally this will
expand puffer into High Fidelity physics
uh just among the environments that we
support so so you can actually do like
pretty solid control got to go join more
often speak if you're interested just
shoot me a follow see you around thanks
for dropping
by using Isaac gy torch doesn't let me
use vs code so I isolated compile and
import
local I
see I guess that
works it's just annoying to have to
distribute it with puff like you have to
distribute it with puffer Li then
right unless you make a separate pit
package out of gym
torch is that what you
did you need to have a standalone gym
torch pip package
or the yeah but if you put it in the end
repo you got to distribute gym torch
with puffer lib which I don't even think
you can do cuz that's Nvidia code I
don't even think you can do that
running and then some of these are are
not actually so let's let's go
look
oops we don't need wrap tensor this is
imported
torch running
headless without debugger gym torch
seems to
work yeah we need to get a I need to
make sure it renders as well in the
docker I haven't gotten there yet um to
give you an idea so this is 959 lines I
haven't optimized any of these we
probably don't need all of these so
really the
the core environment code that we're
dealing with
here okay so this
is this is their old like the Fizz hoi
humanoid en I think it was 600 some odd
lines I've gotten it down to 323 lines
and then the base environment
here I've gotten it down to 130 109
lines so
it's substantially shorter than
before and it doesn't have a million
freaking functions
either cannot change and
distribute Isaac Jim preview
Jim Isaac Sim is
uh Isaac Jim is open source it's Apache
oh maybe we can distribute gy torch then
actually wait yeah yeah yeah we can
distribute
this so we can do whichever to be fair I
still think it's better to not have to
include all the freaking gym torch and
puffer
lib you know I figure that it would be
probably what we should do is we just
should have um you know we should just
have a download of of Isaac gym that
works that's fixed up and we'll just
stick it on a container for them we'll
probably will put it on our main
container as well just so people can use
it but it won't be in puffer
lib I think that's the best thing to do
where did I get this numb inner
iterations from where I got it from
somewhere downloading
installing well this is why we'd put it
on a container I mean cuz like
regardless they're going to have to set
up Isaac gy right like they have to set
it up regardless we're not we can't
bundle Isaac Jim itself with puffer lib
so like regardless of whether we put gym
torch like there's no point in putting
gym torch in puffer lib cuz we can just
fix it and I ISAC in fact I fixed it in
Isaac with one line I don't know if you
saw
was I just
added uh the source files right here so
it actually moves the source files to
the correct spot that's all so we can
totally just like have a version of this
we distribute that's just already
pre-installed on the docker container
right and then we'll just hand the
client the docker container people can
use it through Docker or if they want to
install our version separately they can
do that as
they just had the license on
uh where the hell is the
was Isaac lab is open
sourced is Isaac Sim not open
source is it called
Isaac is this what it is Omniverse Isaac
Sim
is a
j well they have
uh whatever it's like three minor
changes if we have to distribute a like
a PO install script or whatever we will
let me double check
this they open sourced it but then they
have a weird license
Nvidia but they open source the thing
how can they they release the code but
say you can't use it
how does that make any sense
the heck is the license like this
doesn't make
this seems like something we have to
bring up
did I get
off
okay
um I'll keep on this for a bit I this is
we're this doesn't affect us at the very
least cuz it's just
um and we have a rapper anyways it's
whatever
we might have to distribute some like
post install script or whatever
start Sim Prem Flex H there's an
underscore my
bad creates
Sim
okay
device Graphics
device physics
engine Rams
the following argument types are
supported Isaac
Jim a compute
device
let me see it this is create Sim I can
find it
now this should
be we'll do compute device
so be compute
device
yay not
connected did this
run I think it
all but I'm not doing this I'm rendering
on my local machine
really wait we include the appropriate
components in the sample Docker
file
oh hang on
they uh they fixed it
that's
obnoxious so basically very old
container to render
renders
oh it works
that's
impressive I got it working in a
Docker very
nice and then we
hey man care to explain what you're
doing jior s engineered a fintech firm
looking to get an ml Z your actual
experience just bought hands on ML book
haven't started it properly so
currently I'm working with the uh High
Fidelity physics Sim uh Isaac
gy let me see if there is
where's some
images so you're not able to follow
along because I'm just dealing with
horrible infrastructure mess at the
moment um so this is Isaac
Jim it's a high performance physics
simulator by Nvidia uh it's kind of old
they've released some new stuff but a
lot of people still use this because the
new stuff has some issues uh so I've
been right now I've just been trying to
get the renderer working for this but
generally what's happened with this
library is that three consecutive
generations of PhD students have just
written wrappers over each other's code
so this Sim is really good but the code
to use it is a total nightmare so what
I've been doing today is I've been
stripping down all that code to the bare
minimum trying to get a really simple
nice example uh of this environment up
and running and then integrate it with
puffer lib which is the library I
develop for ultra high performance
reinforcement learning and if I'm able
to get all this stuff working this
basically we'll have this very nice high
performance physics Sim that people like
combined with my popular very very high
performance easy to use reinforcement
learning library so a lot of High
Fidelity continuous uh control stuff
will get a lot easier that's currently
what I'm working on
has I think this this renders now I see
I mean it's part of what I stream
for okay so this is the Isaac gy
renderer we got the viewer we got the
Sim we got perf this all works now
there's nothing loaded into it there's
no scene or anything because it's just
the base n but this actually works num
instances is zero in renderer nothing to
do okay so that actually doesn't look
great um maybe the screen shouldn't be
black maybe there should at least be
like a background scene
color but hey I got something to run and
it ran first try on the code so I think
that that's pretty damn
good as soon as I fixed up all the Isaac
Jim errors code ran first try that's
pretty damn
instances do you suggest to do a
master's and then a PhD n ml um I assume
that you're not in the US so in the US
you don't do a master's and then do a
PhD you go straight from undergrad into
PhD and some PHD programs allow you to
get a master's as part of your PhD
program but typically if you get a
master's in the US then that's like a
negative for doing a PhD
uh I only suggest doing a PhD if you're
really sure that you want to do a PhD
basically so in my case I did a PhD
because I had a very specific project
that I needed 5 years to fully develop
in order to advance a specific area of
of Science and I wasn't going to be able
to do it in industry and it was way too
premature to do as a startup so that's
why I did a PhD
um you pretty much have a very strong
reason for wanting to do a PhD because
you know it's 5 years of your life um
you can do a lot of other things in five
years it's five years with not a ton of
funding and you know having to work
within academic constraints so
yeah suggested to Masters Masters is
fine Masters is quick often depending on
your University you can literally just
do a masters as part of your undergrad
like uh in my undergrad you could just
get a master's as part of your four-year
degree other pretty credible people have
said read a bunch of papers and make
projects and iterate pretty much just
that in fact that's exactly what I
suggest in uh I don't know if you're
interested in RL specifically but for my
stuff I've got on both my X and I
believe do I have it
here yeah I got the RL quickart guide on
puffer doai so this is all of my tips on
how to get into reinforcement learning
and I also have this video which is like
a nice overview of the current landscape
of
RL I want to get into Ai and Healthcare
lost okay I didn't see that part yeah it
depends what branch of AI in healthcare
you don't need to do a PhD to be an AI I
will say I mean it makes it easier to
get hired at specific research Labs but
AI is changing so much like it's going
to be a totally different field in 5
years you know you're going to be really
annoyed because the field is going to
look completely different in 5 years
from what you do
now why is Masters looked down on it's
not looked down on in general it's only
that like you don't tend to do a masters
followed by a PhD um because a masters I
I guess if you did it integrated in your
undergrad maybe but they basically
you're they're going to make you do it
anyways and it's like 2 years extra or a
year extra and then you're going to do 5
years as a PhD it's just too
much like you typically you pick one or
the other and you do
that that's only in the US uh in Europe
I believe that they do their masters in
two years or whatever and then they do
their PHD in two or three years it's
different in the typically you do your
undergrad you either do straight to PhD
or you work for like a maximum of two
years you join a startup you join a big
tech company something like that and
then you apply and you know within a
couple years you don't want to wait too
long after undergrad you go back and do
your
PhD thank you so much nothing too
focused on open to really just want a
better Healthcare through Tech yeah it
very much is if you know if if I weren't
working on this I probably be working on
that the main problem with healthcare
for me is that there's just so much
regulation uh it's really hard to do
anything fast I like to be I like to
work in spaces where I can just solve
stuff overnight super fast if I'm you
know if I'm clever if I'm doing stuff
the right way um you know literally just
the last week I rewrote an hyper pram
algorithm in a day and it's like
completely changed the way that I'm
looking at the field now um it's hard
hard to do that type of thing when
there's like 5 years of regulatory
approval Canada's more European I don't
know how it works in
Canada it might be that Canada might
have the European
model but in the US your phds are five
or six years you do them after undergrad
typically some places maybe there's a
way to cut off years with a master but
like with MIT if you don't get your
masters from MIT they make you redo it
anyways so it's like do we want a master
student who's like going to have to redo
you know it's like you're kind of
wasting your time spinning your wheels
at that
point it's just it's too
why yeah so this is fine this is obvious
there's nothing to render because I
haven't set up any environments this is
fine only issue with Healthcare it's so
archaic so much work yeah I I really
don't like spaces that force you to move
slow I get bored when stuff is slow I
get bored and when I get bored I can no
longer focus on my work and I like lose
all excitement um
I don't
know I think like I like I'm interested
in like crazy out there stuff in
healthcare like I don't know can we get
AI to design Nanobots that like I don't
know remove all the buildup in Our
arteries and like I don't know kill
disease cell like kill back like kill
viruses and stuff that sounds
cool that sounds completely insane but
fun to think about
can we do
that by 2050 I would like to be able to
run a 1 hour marathon and to deadlift
5,000 lb I don't know AI get us there
somehow
okay I mean this test seems to work so
let's do the other one which I'm sure
will take much
longer nanot yeah I'm sure because it's
like some sci-fi stuff but like you know
what's the point of getting up in the
morning to work on this [ __ ] if you
can't build some sci-fi I'll build some
sci-fi you know
I'll probably write a fun article at
some point here I actually I have one
silly article that's on
X I really like this
article
fun it's like kind of tongue and cheek
but also kind of serious
self.
Sim just pull the fizi
code my
gosh 8:52 let give another half hour
maybe an
hour lately it's literally been if I'm
not sleeping exercising or eating I'm
coding
it's been a
lot but I got a little trip lined up for
next week so I'll get a bit of
rest got to get this stuff done though
first for client
self.
Sim all right this is in base
me where the hell is self.
Sim create
Sim oh wait hold
on is their garbage code being
garbage self. Sim equals self. jim.
creat
Sim all right
m we add
M eight
hose
name
String group
int invoked
with
and
none failed to okay failed to load is
why
Fizz
data
okay so invoked
with Jim and
asset
transform
barks name
group
filter that looks good to me so let me
just see if they're out of order or some
weird
thing in the docks
okay n
asset pose name group
filter segmentation
I'm sure I'm just misreading it and
there's like a type
mismatch ah lowercase
ID see just a
typo uh okay uh get
actor cannot be used
please use the tensor API if
that 9
p.m. I like to at least get this thing
to run if I get this thing to run I can
clean it up tomorrow and I'm confident
that have this done in
time double check some messages
this okay
so they call this
here cannot be
used after the simulation starts
well you created the N instances
here what do you call
Super well this is hold on this is
create
M what do you call
this and there's create
Sim so you call create
Sim for
yeah why aren't we doing
this I actually don't know what the hell
they're doing
tensor okay so we get
this
um then we break point here and figure
out what the
wait
what hang on where the [ __ ] where is
this
right so this dies on create
actor because
what let me see what the hell's wrong
with
this
so it's in the
loop it's in the create M's
Loop where is it so right
here begin aggregate so create and begin
Aggregate and then they call build m
different well no it's
not hey how's it
nid D so these are fine right and
[Music]
then they call create actor
here no idea
though it's like if I'm not eating
sleeping or exercising I'm probably
live ran 4 kilm today at a 9:30 pace
which I would say is not badad
for literally day three of running from
being out of the
hospital uh tomorrow will be 5
kilomet probably a 10-minute Pace we'll
see
how bad was the pneumonia it nearly
killed
me almost didn't make it to
28 luckily I ran 1500 miles last year so
I was in pretty damn good
shape if IID run 500 I would have been
actor where's create M
called I see create actor is
okay so they do create
n and then begin
Aggregate and then they call build
en which is
I don't think I'm doing anything that I
shouldn't be allowed
here create actor this is crashing on
create actor are
simulate
okay wait
this is in
right this is in freaking
innit
right andless my am I stupid here
what's what's going on oh wait did I put
the okay hold
on I think it's not here
right okay yeah it's not
here not here right
ah you don't call prepare Sim until
you're ready to prepare the damn Sim
apparently
Cuda if you have a modern GPU just use
puffer tank it's easier it comes
pre-installed uh Nidia
SMI
12.4 driver version 550 like just use
puff tank all you need is your base
NVIDIA drivers on your system and puffer
tank will take care of everything else
it's really easy to Dev in and if you
use VSS code you can trivially connect
vs code to The
Container this is another thing for you
to pick up I highly highly suggest
picking up containerized
development virtual M suck cond sucks
all the other tooling on python sucks
you just get a Docker container and then
you never have problems again
it's
great these are like tips I'm giving you
that will save you many many hundreds of
hours just container it
you don't need containers for Everything
But as soon as you have a project that
has moderately annoying dependencies
which is basically everything in AI
because of Cuda you just throw it in a
container and you're
happy and if you break your container
it's literally 5 Seconds to reset it
hey stick around you'll learn some cool
stuff ask in terms of mlot projects what
would be the best way to make sort of
make something of
worth would it be a full stack
application they could have user
base
regards I mean it depend depends on your
level of experience the absolute basics
for getting into machine learning is one
very easy
course do
this this is at least as of the last
time I've checked the best course in
deep learning go watch the lectures
online by either Justin or Andre either
of those two lectures will be the good
ones um do the assignments you'll
Implement your own autograd this will
give you foundational experience in ml
without giving you obsessive amounts of
math that don't really
help this is like the
base wouldn't suck as much
in yeah hey build some cool M's
I mean that's the most advising I do
really is like people submit
environments that they've built some are
small some are medium some are quite
large and complex and I code review the
entire thing so when people submit me
very shitty code I give them tons of
code style tips when people submit me
very good code I think about how to
restructure things when people have RL
errors in their code I explain to them
why you want to design design things a
certain way to make it easier for RL so
on and so
complexity let's say that the complexity
would be about how many lines the code
base would be if I wrote
it let's say
that what's going on here ultra high
performance reinforcement learning Dev
my friend
my Blinder is this the
wrong
uh and from there after the Stanford
course what's the next step if you look
at my quick start guide you can apply
the same reasoning to basically any
other subfield of ml uh You' would
familiarize yourself with the top
let's say the top 10 most important
papers in the last 10 years in the sub
field that you care about or in the
specific area that you care about you
probably should expand to more than that
over time but let's start with
10 you'd start off doing some projects
doing some like do some applications do
some research get some
experience get you know a feel for how
to make things actually work and go from
there it's generally how things
work okay so I just did this out of
order uh low
equals what was the other
for
C I didn't recommend you a course for C
cs106x is taught in
C++ C++ is not fun but it's just a core
algorithms and data structures
course you at least need one core
algorithms in data structures course the
C++ is very painful but
yeah dude am I just trolling what's
wrong with
me box low high shape D
type
noow
High
shape oh I didn't do it here dumbass
getting tired doing stupid [ __ ] um got
it understood thank you now you're good
just why I stream get people involved
with stuff right and hey who knows maybe
people want to come over to RL to do
some cool stuff because in RL you can
actually make awesome progress without
owning 2,000
gpus so it's pretty fun
it's going to solve tons and tons of
industrial processes as
well
okay RL
what so this is what I
develop ultra high performance
reinforcement learning
library all these environments run a
million steps per second per CPU core
they run on web the trained agents run
on web you can play the games yourself
if I just press shift I'll take over for
this bot that's playing here take my
hands off the bot takes over you can do
it with you know all sorts of different
environments here's Enduro here's a
freaking full
MMO we got all sorts of fun stuff here
we got a mooba all sorts of stuff um
like 100 to a thousand times faster than
most of the field and very very easy to
use so this is what I'm currently
building all free all open source
contributor Le it's a fun time
indeed if I sound mildly irritable it's
just because I've
been coding for a good 12 hours
today so
far nope no RL for LMS when you do RL
for LMS that when I got to go raise 50
million in VC and go deal with that
mess I'm very happy not having to deal
with that and working on something a bit
different from what most people are
doing at the
moment this is going to solve a lot of
problems a lot cheaper than llms and a
lot better as
well best paying position in the field
of ml
um if you mean just like cash comp and
such and like not uh doing your own
thing then open AI probably or
anthropic need a seven figure
suggest I mean yeah it's like if you
want to work on like Frontier llm stuff
and make seven figures you go to like um
to open AI or anthropic or X you you
know one of the big Labs that's very
well
funded I mean you've got to be
good at least reasonably good
you I mean it's not like it was more
Serendipity than anything I I uh I had
published a single author paper in
natural language processing and I was at
nurs and Ilia gave a cool talk about
like the need for developing more RL
environments and I went up to him after
the talk and said hey I'm building the
exact stuff that you're talking about
but I'm an undergrad with two
gpus um and he sent me over to
Phillip who was doing some work at open
AI uh and I chatted with philli I got
interviews it was a very good interview
process they basically had me give a
presentation to the company and then
chat with three of their researchers for
an hour a piece and they were like okay
you know you're super motivated to do
this research you have generally you
know what you're talking about and I got
an internship and then after that I
followed Philip to MIT and Philip became
my
adviser got 20 take credits and AWS GPU
instances those will go really fast cuz
they're very
overpriced personal setup with 192 gigs
vram depends what gpus you have though
is the thing the obnoxious thing about
um language models I guess you can maybe
do something with like a multi 490 rig
or something but really like oh vram not
Ram do you have a bunch of 800s
you can probably do some small
stuff I mean still even with like a
decent local setup though like the labs
have the labs have like several thousand
times
that I mean if you have eight gpus they
have 80,000
gpus so just like the fact that you can
run one experiment at a time for several
days it's very very difficult to do
stuff that
way six
,000 you can dabble and do a few things
with that if you
want I don't know see the thing with RL
like here let me show you this when I
say we can do stuff
fast there I think we're on a different
page about this scale that we're talking
here so we only have like nine gpus in a
cluster nine different
machines um
but like I can run literally thousands
of experiments on these and I can get
like comprehensive results on basically
anything that I want because all of our
stuff is so fast here this is 20
experiments that I ran on neural MMO 3
starting this morning which is probably
our heaviest environment still 20
environments completed you can start to
see uh where is it menom Prof
now we're starting to get some results
here here's 168 experiments I ran in
about a day on a different environment
here's comprehensive analysis of how
much compute you have to spend to get
each level of result I have the same
thing for a half dozen other
environments and I can just continue
running these constantly on like just a
couple of
gpus so like that's a very different
scale and a very different level of you
know confidence in your results compared
to you can kind of run a small model
like one at a time and do some stuff
it's very
annoying going to LM development is Main
Source are wait so you
[Music]
see I mean no not necessarily it's
consistent I mean the alternative is you
start your own thing right in any area
of
AI engine RL would be making big money
soon the thing is
like if I wanted to work on llms I could
be very very good on llms within two
months like it's all the same stuff
engineering skill transfers basically
everywhere in
Ai and most of the algorithms are pretty
darn like in architectures are pretty
darn similar at this point there's
really not a massive Gap
I've worked in natural language
processing I've worked in computer
vision now I work in reinforcement
learning it's really not that easy to
switch around actually rl's kind of the
hardest one cuz RL takes the most
engineering except for maybe the guys
that make the gpus run fast like in a
massive Distributing setting your
compute is slow though
what oh yeah his Compu
yeah and those cards are pricey
too our boxes are about uh 5 grand 50
between 4,000 and 5500 a piece for a
full you know a full training
box so I mean it's more than you know
more than a usual desktop you'd buy but
in the scheme of AI really really
cheap you know we can get a cluster we
have like our current cluster is I think
Grand and uh the new cluster will get
with 40 nodes will be less than a quar
million for 40
machines and still very pricey for me
but it's like in the scheme of things
not much where are you buying main
gear we've gotten all our stuff from
main gear so far they're pretty
good stuff goes wrong with desktops cuz
you know they're desktops but uh
support's pretty good markups pretty low
it's
nice it's better than nothing yeah RL
project pick any IND like pick any
industrial problem that you're
interested in that's like framed as a
learn from simulator and do that
that what would you suggest someone with
experience in deep
learning to venture into Ro for Robotics
and Hardware if they're good
projects suggest to start with the gain
experience
um I mean you're probably looking at
stuff like playing around with uh mjx
like the fast new vectorized
maoko or Isaac Isaac a pain um yeah
probably mjx stuff is probably the
nicest know getting some stuff up and
running is
important getting some uh you know
getting some humanoids to do some stuff
or quadrupeds to do some
stuff
um for like relatively newer
people you there's there's going to be a
minimum bar right like you have to at
least know the basics of you got at
least know the basics um but probably
looking for startups to join would be
the easiest thing
capacity why is RL compute expensive
it's not uh less expensive I didn't see
the less uh because we just need 490s
and we only really need one per machine
I can train it a million steps per
second on a 4090 I can literally train
on more data than gp4 on one
GPU we have infinite data and it like we
have infinite data and we get it at over
a gigabyte a second we can train on a
gigabyte of data per second it's a very
different scale of things can we see
some coding now please yep good point I
got distracted because I'm half asleep
um I was trying to figure out why the
hell all these body IDs are negative one
where do these get set
humanoid
handles join paid or
unpaid depends on your level of
experience ideally if you're doing
something useful you get
paid and
um startups generally don't like it when
you ask for high cash comp so if you if
you can get paid in mostly Equity plus
like basic living expenses that's uh
that's ideal because startups it
depending on how much they've raised
they only have so much runway to burn so
they're happier to give more Equity a
lot of them and also like your Equity
isn't worth anything unless the startup
does well so you're very incentivized to
help them do
well that's mostly why
so these handles are all going to be
zero because we're only
adding one humanoid per en I
believe so these are all zero but that's
issue don't need to preload the models
are absolutely tiny in
RL uh between 100,000 parameters and I
mean the biggest models in RL are like
168 million but you're never going to
see that outside of really large
industry projects
but the thing is we solve problems with
that we actually solve stuff with that
Isn't that
cool okay so I'm confused as to
why the feet are
not the feet are not in
here let me figure this out this is
screwing up because the feet are not in
here for some reason
reason okay so I changed the contact
bodies
here oh wait hold on
you can just add stuff to these I
think I think I can just add
these I think it's that easy I think you
just do
foot left I have no idea how this
actually
Juniors well I mean how do you think
companies work do you think that's any
different like yeah you got to develop
some skills
I mean the way to get hired is to get
good fast
right I worked damn hard when I
started I work pretty hard now but I
worked harder then
right it's just trickier to get into
specialized like research or science you
know ml
positions uh as a junior because usually
it's it's like it's actually kind of one
of the things that a masters is decent
for is getting into like some like ml
engineering position you know that's
like if a masters will do that for
you and that's like you can do that in
your if you're smart you can do that
during your four-year degree depending
on your University or in just one extra
year ideally you do it in your degree
you don't pay for it
there one nice thing about PhD they
don't pay you much but at least you
don't pay for
years
okay head
exists does not have a
foot L toe
joints TR I remember learning from
RL a different Tech um stuff like
rainbow is still used which is uh deep Q
learning with the whole kitchen sink of
improvements thrown at it and PO is
still one of the best algorithms out
there in 2017 I believe
published no I should not consider
buying the parts myself man the total
markup is like about
$1,000 per machine um it's worth it's
not worth my time to spend like you know
several hours assembling and then
troubleshooting and all of that I spend
enough damn time on cluster maintenance
as is it's absolutely not worth my
40% I mean based on the parts I've
looked up it's like on a $5,500 machine
it's about 1,300 at most
I wouldn't be sure that that's better
than rainbow to be
honest there really aren't enough
environments it's possible that looks
decent but I don't know the thing that
you're thinking
website I thought I had
it oh here it
is all right this is from high
school all right like this is from high
school I've built [ __ ] I've built like a
good I don't know half dozen different
PCS it's just not worth the
time okay why is this not being
found find actor rigid body handle
n
pointer actor
handle body
[Music]
name humanoid
you can do
that that's perfectly valid
yeah I'd rather put that time into
trying to find you know a third
contract like you know third fourth
fifth contracts for
puffer I'm already saving so much money
by having the cluster in the first place
versus renting the uh know versus
getting the machines off of AWS or
GCE I'm very confused as to
why why this is
not ke bodies
freaking maybe GPT has seen enough Isaac
gim code who knows I don't know what's
wrong with this the Sim is
freaking kind of cursed
it's hard for me to recommend a path I
wouldn't want to take myself
right Health Care later I mean like it
makes sense
but like it makes sense but it's not
something I would do personally so like
it's hard to
recommend Arch on a Surface
yeah I mean it depends where you are in
your life
right if you're single in your early 20s
it's like you can kind of do whatever if
they're complications then they're
complications why wouldn't you want to
take it cuz Le coding my into
anwe job with other people that have
leak coded their way into the same job
would cause me absolutely [ __ ]
crippling depression
it's I've simply worked too hard to be
comfortable with like to be happy with
doing that
be I don't know I've got some crazy
views about AI in the future that you
know get me up in the
morning
though unlike some of the crazy
doomers they uh don't really have any
immediate implications other than build
a bunch of cool [ __ ] nice and
stuff I mean you can do that pretty
quickly with just about any s like any
software engineering job these days if
you're not spending a
ton I mean the thing is it's like all
they're all in super high cost of living
areas where doing anything is very
expensive so you got to be a little bit
you kind of don't get to have much fun
in that sense for a bit but yeah
I don't know man it really depends on
how like it really depends on how good
you are and how many years you've got
like to learn stuff before
then I tried to do like I tried to do
like PhD research positions out of
undergrad and it's like obviously people
are like no dude come back after you've
done your
PhD but then by the time I've done my
PhD I don't really want to do that
anymore I want to do my own thing you
know get actor rigid but did you just
make this function up GPT you dumb piece
of
[ __ ]
H I've gotten a little bit vulgar and IR
a at this hour because again I've been
coding since I don't know like 7:30 or
8:00 a.m. it's almost 10: so pardon my
French
you did it
again a stupid
thing ever thought about returning to
the West Coast I
do I uh I'm in Florida with family for
the colder months and I spent some
months in the summer in
paloalto I can kind of work from
wherever I just need a like I just need
my desktop set up in a
gym that's all I
need ideally somewhere to
run so occasionally I have to figure out
server maintenance
Shenanigans assuming you're a junior
software engineering with minimal AI
I mean it depends on how hard you're
willing to work and how good you are at
learning stuff
um probably the most realistic thing to
aim for would be like an applied ml
position I think that they still have
those with
um I think that they still have those
without like Master's requirements or
anything they're mostly positions where
companies are throwing relatively simple
ml models at their specific
that but it depends are you're going to
be happy doing that it's it sounds like
you want to do something initially to
get yourself into a good spot which is
totally
valid best
responses
to wait to
equal
bio with the
code I probably shouldn't be using 40
either
everything doesn't that mess you up
longer term cuz it's like storing
everything h that's
funny okay so wait this
has this is finding the indices doesn't
have left foot and right foot so let's
get rid of those I don't actually know
where these came from cuz I didn't see
it in the
there find
gem wait find
asset can I just do
this wait M pointer no because this is
just of the humanoid
I don't know I don't really I'm not
really a power user
of
llms I mostly just use it to see like
hey like I'm not really using it to try
to figure this out I'm using it to see
if it happens to have you know the uh it
happens to have this in its code from
like you know it's indexed some
weird like some weird random Forum post
or something that has this code in it so
basically using it as a fuzzy search
engine if it doesn't know I don't keep
trying to get it to figure it out right
it's like okay not in dock cool
I know should I go get deep seek gar1
whale
model or does it report all of
your prompts to the Chinese government
his study for
midterms dude High School
sucked that's the actual hardest I've
ever worked [ __ ]
hell why do I have eight people watching
me suffer
through this ridiculous
API that's kind of
funny well this will be pretty nice once
uh once it
works this will be probably less than
half the length of the original Isaac
gym code which was God awful and like a
fifth of the number of methods
so they should make it substantially
easier to deal with Isaac Isaac gem once
it works it's not bad for having only
been working on this for a
this H you shouldn't be suffering
through things like this things should
just be easy like
when I'm writing C environments right
all of our M's and puffer are in pure C
it's the easiest damn thing ever it's
great you can build all sorts of awesome
stuff so quickly and everything is
simple and easy and just makes sense and
then I do this and it's some God awul
python API that has no freaking error
checking and is just horrible
if you want to specialize in
RL I've laid the groundwork for
you just got to get building some stuff
after your
midterms see is simpler it's also faster
though and lets you build tons of stuff
so what's the excuse why is this
complicated C is the
worst have you read our C
code it's real
easy
here I'm going to sell you on this in
like basically no lines of code
here's our multi-agent snake environment
it runs at several million steps per
second on One
Core there you go it's 325 lines of
brain dead easy
look at the
file just open the file like open the
snake file read that that's multi-agent
snake at millions of steps per
second this is in fact neovim
here we have like we have a dozen of
those some of them are are better
written than others um we've got a full
MOBA we've got an
MMO written in
C no no no no seg fults aren't a problem
see the thing that the problem is nobody
told you about this little flag right
here
um right here nobody told you about this
uh F sanitize this flag right
here and then this tells you when you're
at a bound in memory and catches like
95% of your seg faults and tells you
exactly why and then you don't have that
problem
anymore they didn't tell me about that
in undergrad either and I didn't like
see an undergrad
sucks I'd really like to at least fix
this bug tonight and I can't think of
why this would be the case is it like
somehow
MMO these agents are running in your
browser it's got leveling it's got items
it's got equipment it's got trade an
economy there's also this MOA this is
written in
C this is like a League of Legends or
defensive agents these agents are
running in your browser they're five
unique characters with skills and you
know all sorts of abilities they're
creeps they're neutrals hostiles
it's also in
C got lots of
stuff one if I got against C++ it gives
you it gives programmers too many ways
to get clever and too clever for their
own
them stop being clever be real stupid do
everything stupid do it stupidest way
possible it'll be
that oops wrong wrong one I actually
managed to comment out the wrong block
of code that's how tired I
am I got to go to sleep
soon I really won't fix a
bug dude we've all been there you're not
going to get any good instruction out of
that I made Minecraft mods to start
programming I made some
why is this LOL somebody else took the
freaking
username where is
it that's so funny literally in the last
few
months oh there it is yeah I made some
shitty
mods want Dev is essential
doesn't have to be nothing better about
writing clever
C++ kind of a
nightmare yeah Java's Java actually
teaches you negative programming you
actually are a worse programmer uh for
learning Java than for if you do not
ever touch Java
I'm really confused as to how this thing
doesn't
work did I screw up the signature
somehow
this
function find
actor find actor rigid body handle
pointer handle body
name humanoid
handles no I have it right so is this
this not getting registered
somehow I'm wait what I'm losing
credibility for having written Java in
when I was
lnns I actually don't know what that is
what architecture is
that link paper
liquid
I is this a thing
right it
allows well then I can tell you it's not
going to be useful right off the
bat you're losing credibility since
you're denouncing dude it's like it's
actually impossible to write good code
in
Java let me give you an
example so this thing here Robo code
this is uh a tool an environment it's
like a bot fighting game that was used
to teach Java the source code for this
is tens of thousands of lines and has
hundreds of files in Java this prototype
is like 300 lines of c and is about a
thousand times faster if not 10,000
times faster and I have a guy working on
this now and it's going to be feature
complete with the original in less than
a th Total Lines so yes jav is
it's literally like how to write good
jva is just how to write bad code it's
like anti pattern
hell did I miss a line
here
set depth of
field set actor
properties I actually don't know what's
wrong
here this looks to
be exactly the same
you kidding dude is there a PDF for this
toight you don't have to
freaking random M
paper
c c is like kind of
okay there's pretty good tooling around
it it's what you it's what Unity uses
I've had to write some C it's like
moderately less bad I
it I mean to be fair Unity is not not
really C it's like its own framework
thing so it's kind of a domain specific
version of
it go
die scj
store Robo code
well we were reimplementing it in C cuz
the Java version
sucks you can't use the it's too first
of all it's a mess to even get working
second of all it's way too
slow so I made a prototype of it and now
we have a contributor who's finishing
it that's been a pretty good pattern as
I prototype stuff and then I finally
contributed to finish
CU it lets me get like the key data
structures correct
action build action PD
offsets let's
see PD offsets
right okay so they do create
M and then hold on there's a super
create Ms that I
missed isn't
sucks oh wait wa wait I know I know I
know what it is
I think I
know I bet it's
this I bet this has to go
here where is it called prepare
base okay so it calls prepare Sim in the
init so where is
where's super in it
is
huh oh wait wait no because it's the
weird thing okay give me one second let
me I just got to finish this thought
Sim and then if I go back here [ __ ]
objectoriented programming is a piece of
[ __ ] and this is why
um this calls okay so super create
s is
here oh wait no this creates the Sim and
then it creates the
and I just have to do
this and
this goes right after PD
control wise
Sim
now
okay let me see
archive
version and math everywhere that you've
sent me at this
hour update by OD solver this is there's
no way this is
fast there's just no way this is fast
right
all right until I'm told this is fast
it's like
no want to ask you said opening it ship
meeting Ilia and
three yeah I uh I published so I did a
lot of research I did the full core of
my undergrad degree my freshman year I
started doing research at the start of
my sophomore year I done some research
before that but I started again then and
after about 6 months of research I uh
submitted and published my first paper
which was a single author NLP paper um
wasn't amazing paper but you know it was
a published paper and I went to nurs to
present that I happened to go to a talk
that IL was giving he was talking about
some of the early DOTA stuff and Robo
Sumo and all this RL I'd already started
coding up neural MMO as a side project
at this point and he was talking about
the need for more complex environments
so you know this was at my jam so I
talked I went up and talked to him about
that he sent me over to his colleague
Phillip who then interviewed me as like
a pre-round then I got invited to go to
the HQ I was local to the area and I
gave a presentation open to uh open to
the company that was their interview
process then I had like three 1hour
chats with various researchers had lunch
with with the company and I got an offer
after that and I ended up spending six
months there and after that I followed
Philip to MIT because he was going to be
a professor there so I followed him
there for my PhD
oops there we go that was it
you had to prepare the
Sim so I just had to prepare Sim in the
wrong
spot add open
AI what do you mean add open AI
internship
yeah no I'm I've graduated my PhD I
finished my PhD last spring puffer AI is
a company I founded this and I'm working
on puffer full time open AI no longer
does the stuff that I was they're
working on they just do language models
now it's not the same company
trolling uh okay yeah
here
um there really not anything I can do
with this
now so how are you making money if
everything's open source we're not
making a ton of money yet but we do have
Revenue I'll show
you and what I'm doing right now is
technically for a
client we sell service
packages so we make these tools uh
they're very good they're incredibly
fast they're very easy to use we're
really pushing the frontiers of
reinforcement learning so if you have a
company that has a problem that requires
reinforcement learning that you're
having a tough time with which you
probably are cuz reinforcement learning
is hard why wouldn't you want us on your
side right we sell service contracts
starting at 10K a
month which for a decent chunk of my
time is a pretty darn good
price and it ramps up from there you
know I have PhD buddies I can bring in
as contractors for larger projects of
this is this being one of them
so that's what we do goal is in the next
several months to scale this so that we
have five consistent clients which would
be 50k a month in Revenue which would be
more than enough for us to uh you know
continue funding Hardware
expenses and large bounties and you know
other things around in the community
this is not an amazing business model by
any means but it's a viable
one you know this is not as much money
as I could make doing other stuff
but I it's perfectly serviceable and I
think it can scale reasonably well while
also letting me revolutionize the field
how are you
splitting payments you mean with
contractors so the base is 10K that
covers my time if they want if they want
a contractor puffer charges 10K and the
contractor gets 7.5 which is just about
the best possible rate you will find
anywhere in
Consulting usually they keep less than
half we charge the client 10K they get
7.5 and that's that's intended to be for
quarter time work so 10 hours a
week it's mainly for PhD students it's
like hey you can double your stipend in
10 hours a
week mind you the work is what the work
is the expectation is it probably should
only take you about 10 hours a week if
it takes you longer it takes you longer
but that's about the size that they're
supposed to
be that's not considered an amazing rate
um it's a pretty good rate it's not an
amazing
rate will you operate as a startup with
having engineers and
employees uh when we get larger
potentially
yes but not until we have the consistent
Revenue to support that
hey I'm sure you'll be good in uh in a
few years right contribute some cool
stuff in the meantime I want to get once
we get a little more Revenue right I'm
going to probably start putting up
bounties on various
things like here one of the things that
and also there are other cool things so
like there's this collab with NYU where
probably in the next couple weeks we're
going to need somebody to uh contribute
a major piece of C
code to an environment port and that'll
be authorship on a
publication so there will be you know
academic collabs as
well what are your goals for the next
quarter I don't operate in
quarters quarters are too
short I think about the year and in the
year the goal is to make reinforcement
learning 10 times easier on to get
working on a new
problem so in the first like 8 months or
so of puffer we made thousand times
faster environments in training so we
can run so many more experiments than
ever before and we made a nice stable
training system for that good
hyperparameter sweep Integrations lots
of things to make training nice and easy
in the next phase we're going to take
that we're going to do more science side
work in order to make the algorithms and
training much more stable and therefore
easier to get working on new problems
uh this needs to
go wait missing single observation
space uh this has single observation
space missing required attribute
funny am I being dumb
here is this defined as a property or
something
property
single have it spelled wrong single
observation space
Loops you will enjoy the loop oh I'm
dumb as hell I see the
problem this is just this is why I
should just go to
bed cuz I'm starting to do stupid [ __ ]
where is
this hold
on currently suffering from decision
paralysis worked on stuff from web apps
embedded SE small ml stuff
okay good engineering
background so made me interested in too
many
things I just have been doing ml since I
was like 14
man
um I did NLP for a bit I was kind of
boring I did some vision for a bit it
was kind of boring and then I stumbled
on RL and it was like whoa this is this
is the thing for long-term Ai and I
still think it is I still think that
language models aren't everything
um it's also you tested on games which
is fun it can solve lots of like
interactive
processes rl's good and it's like it
really rewards
engineering it rewards a lot of stuff to
be fair it was quite miserable for
several years before I got good enough
at the engineering to really crank on it
um but now it's
awesome you know you don't like you're
allowed to do tons of different stuff as
well like you don't have to
do like the thing is that engineering
skill is so core like the BET like if
you're a good engineer you can float
around and do whatever you really
can but like actually a good engineer
not like the type of fang engineer who
gets paid a million dollars a year to
create more
problems next breakthrough on the
horizon for RL um ultra high quality
hyper parameter sweeps
we uh I did this last weekend we've beat
the heck out of a of the best existing
hyperparameter sweep algorithm and
there's still some ideas I have left I
think we're going to get ridiculously
good hyperparameter sweeps that are
going to cut down on the experimentation
uh Time by a factor of about four or
five
I mean this is kind of why I stream
stuff it's kind of cool right it's like
watch reinforcement
learning breakthroughs happen
good plus good for the community good
for for lots of
stuff this is a community project after
all
yeah I'm going to do a big blog post on
it you I've done that several times now
though I've like I've talked about it
several times on
stream there's a bunch of math I'm not
great at math my math is actually very
very
mediocre oh cool we got past a
net um my yeah my math is very very
mediocre but uh you know no it's we're
making it
work yeah but of course your math is
mediocre you're like 16 I'm an MIT
PhD and better not ask me to do any
stats
ah you're at the bottom 20% of your
class dude there's no
way all right you you you are too young
to be at the bottom of your current math
class no no no that's no
excuse learn your freaking calculus
you're allowed to get bored when you get
into the obnoxious theoretical math
courses that seem to have no link to
anything not before
then less than a 98 is a
fail oh that just means your grading
system is is [ __ ] if it's a force
curve at 98 that's just [ __ ]
I don't believe
that I don't think that's true
anywhere I went to a very good private
school and uh it was only really the top
10% of the
class that was any
good like I think the top 20 people go
to IV
from U my high school mostly Yale it's a
feeder to Yale and then like it's
usually like two or three to Stanford
and a few other
Jersey it looks like a good school 13 to
one
teacher holy
hell wa is this only if you submit
it is this only if you voluntarily
submit your score
though oh okay 82 MIT
oh interested in
colleges dude why are you complaining
about your curriculum then like
obviously you have the same shitty AP
curriculum as everyone CU it's the
[ __ ]
AP yeah that's good I was in Connecticut
yeah New England has the best high
schools for the most
part the majority of programmers end up
being like programmers are all mostly
self-taught anyways like the curriculum
doesn't do [ __ ] for you
like your first intro course like gets
out like gives you some Concepts that
you probably
missed get used to
it you think I got [ __ ] out of my intro
series courses no I
didn't except maybe the first
yeah that's cuz software engineering is
really freaking hard to
learn it like honestly it should it
really ought to be like an
apprenticeship model type thing cuz you
kind of just have to learn from somebody
who actually writes good code
like of all the stuff I've learned
getting actually good at engineering has
been the hardest thing like by a
mile like research not that hard science
not that
hard writing code that doesn't make you
want to rip your eyes out very hard
you'd fix that [ __ ] if you want to go to
a decent College holy
way learn to the code from Le code yeah
that doesn't teach you how to code at
all that teaches you [ __ ] all does teach
you how to pass interviews does not
teach you how to write code
you're probably
surrounded by really not me or
how an open Locker
policy I want to know
physics
step assume it's this physics
step all right boss heading
out thanks for dropping
by why do you think company's value
performance and Elite
code CU they don't know how to
interview it takes too much effort and
too much skill to be able to evaluate
people so I don't know
how I can evaluate people provided you
have a decent piece of Open Source Code
to show me
just look at your code and ask you [ __ ]
about it and I'll know in you know 20
minutes if you have any idea what you're
talking
about I'll know if you're good I'll know
if I can work with you you know if your
style of how you think and how you build
stuff matches what I can work with know
everything
and if you tell me that you know you
don't have a single piece of Open Source
Code because you know you've only worked
at closed Source companies and stuff for
the last 20 years and you have no side
projects well then I know that that's a
no as
I mean I don't have I'm
not I don't know
RSD I'm not on the Spectrum but I'm not
exactly the most naturally social
guy I used to be way more reserved and
way less confident uh that's a learnable
skill that is a learnable
skill easier for some people harder for
others but that is a learnable
skill let me tell you a little
story I uh I felt I was like too awkward
and I didn't have the confidence I want
wanted I was just wasn't where I wanted
to be when I got to college which if
you're doing High School right you're
not going to be because you're going to
be in a freaking hole doing work the
whole time you've basically had no
social interaction because you've had no
time um kind of just comes with the
territory not your fault right but
anyways uh they did like dorm elections
it's like well this is kind of
lame I'm not going to do this [ __ ] but
wait so I ordered a stupid Jester hat
jumped up on a table and announced I was
running for dorm fool gave a ridiculous
speech entirely in shakes Bean Pros uh
and was dub and was named dorm fool uh
to a large round of applause and then
every week thereafter at the meetings I
would come up with yet another speech in
the most ridiculous fashion possible
jump up on the table and do the same
thing it's like the most awkward
embarrassing thing you can possibly do
and and it prevents you from feeling
awkward and embarrassed very very
[Music]
quickly very effective I did a whole
bunch of [ __ ] like
that I convinced my um one of the
mandatory English classes I convinced
like half of the more gullible people in
one of my mandatory English classes that
I was from Texas because I would show up
to every single class in a flannel shirt
and a bandana and talk in a terrible
southern accent which since they'd never
actually met anybody from Texas they
didn't know the difference uh I did a
bunch of
[Laughter]
[ __ ] oh that's funny yeah that's a
different that's a different situation
still learnable
I don't know I was told I had
like the labels don't always help I'll
say you know I was told I had like I
don't know like bottom 2% processing
speed or something like that uh when I
was younger it would take me like three
times longer than everyone to finish the
test I'd get like you know i' get a 100
on all the tests but it would take me
like three times longer so that they you
know people would call this a disability
or whatever the [ __ ] didn't
matter turns out didn't matter at all
look at all stuff I'm building sometimes
the labels don't really help
you yeah just find people who aren't
dicks
just find people who aren't dicks man
holy
hell look at Elon richest guy in the
world has done more for attacking
Humanity than anyone
else hasn't stopped him
ah this one's actually used don't
cry and the base
task okay we'll put this up here
wait so were
you is that a
joke it's a joke
progress
buff progress
also the Elon thing they know it's not
that that's just politically motivated
horeshit so it's a little
different like they're not stupid
they're just
lying okay maybe they're a little stupid
yeah wo and behold there are people in
the world who are not honest and lie and
will do whatever the [ __ ] to get what
they want get used to it cut those
people out of your life right
it all right what the hell's wrong with
this thing
um we make the environment right and
then we set the
environment so uh
progress buffer should exist except I'm
[ __ ] and I put it under the viewer
thing that's actually kind of an
argument for not doing this inverted
pattern in giant ass functions like
this R
line it's not borderline ableism dude
they'll do it to everybody
they'll make [ __ ] up about what like
about anybody it's that
hate dude have you seen him speak he's
definitely autistic
this what are we building
here currently we're getting Isaac gem
which
is which is this
thing oops where the cool graphs yeah
this thing all these
Sims uh running with Puffer which is my
high performance reinforcement learning
library and we are undoing three
generations of PhD students worth of bad
rapper code so that we can actually make
this thing fast and
clean put up a
PR C said he gave him speed
up solid 510 I'll take it thank you very
much for that that will be merged anti
oh yeah yeah yeah I had
yeah I had extra time on
tests for a separate
thing time cap on test was stupid
anyways people gave me [ __ ] for it and
it's like all right it's multivariable
CL Cal you're dumbass can have 30 hours
and you won't be able to solve any of it
why is this not why didn't I copy this
thing is this in some other
hoi then how the hell is this getting
called from
this other class this is did I copy this
thing wrong this should this not have
been a
humanoid wait
step compute observations compute
task oh yeah I just totally copied this
thing wrong this thing does doesn't get
the hell out of
how did I miss
this did I miss
this PD tart
tenser is it not just this
one oh this is one ahead I
see
yeah
maybe that's going to be
hard
[Music]
euse I don't even know what blue J
is no idea what that is
probably can you just use them for
Java compilation of that [ __ ] probably
I think we used like eclipse or
something and it
God you know when I wonder how why it
took me several years before I could
like kind of do anything in programming
then I go and look at like the robo code
code base like the stuff I was shown on
this is how you code it's no
wonder that's not how you write code
that's how you require [ __ ] 20 people
to do the work of half of a person with
a brain
index out of
bounds really
to
yep no there is no coin the coin was a
scam by somebody impersonating me
who if I had any recourse would be in
[ __ ] there's no coin there is an
awesome open source Community
project no I'm not making a [ __ ]
that literally does nothing but burn my
reputation for no
about dude I like I actually have to ask
like are you a unique person or are you
the same person on five different
accounts because like like the number of
people who basically come in here and
said the same thing is
obscene like no I'm not rugging a giant
coat like I'm not rugging a coin I'm not
okay I don't care I'm not locking a coin
I'm not rugging a coin I'm not doing
[ __ ] it's like what I am doing is I'm
sitting here and I'm solving
reinforcement learning I've been coding
for like 15 hours
dude I don't
need I don't need a coin to fund things
we have revenue and we'll be getting
more Revenue
like this is not this is not crypto
project this is reinforcement learning
project I don't want to have I don't
want a meme coin to be involved with
this I don't want it to be attached in
any
way like this is serious devs working on
hard
[ __ ] no it's fine it's just like I
legitimately can't tell with the number
of DMS I've gotten at least a decent
chunk of them are from the same damn
person who did who started the coin
so what did you use to learn the code
man I like there were no resources
around them so it took me forever to
actually get
decent um I started making like
Minecraft mods and like random ass games
and action script it was
awful um and then I did some mat lab
which was also was stupid eventually I
got to Python and wrote a bunch of
really bad python for very many
years
and started in research still writing
bad Python and then got really
annoyed by the state of the code and
just tried to write better code for 10
years and then after 10 years of doing
that I started writing some C and within
3 weeks C was very easy because of all
the work I'd put in for the last 10
years
many people do we have on this oh we got
10 people still watching me at 11 p.m.
folks if you have not starred the
repository please star the puffer Fe the
puffer star it really helps out um all
this stuff is free and open source it's
Community project so you know we have
lots of new people building RL
environments all the time it's a great
way to get into
RL I mean this is an intentional choice
right I'm trying to fix I'm trying to
revolutionize a field
and takes a lot of
work I do keep in shape at the very
least what you see now is me after
nearly dying of pneumonia down 20 lbs I
was at like 190 and jacked as hell about
a month ago we'll get that back it'll
take some training though
software principles and
design yeah I honestly I I don't do any
of
those like I don't have patterns I don't
have like I don't have I don't have any
of this I have very simple
code Asma got so bad oh that's freaking
rough I've not had that luckily that's
freaking rough
that powerlifting maybe not too cardio
heavy powerlifting is fun as hell cardio
is really good for you but powerlifting
is
great it gets you in good shape and it's
just good for the soul you know
exercise squat bench dead lift overhead
press pretty well
covered maybe he had some
row I got to stop this pretty soon I'm
like falling asleep but I'm going to
sleep very
observations I can just do
this and then
I'm just do this for
now and figure the task stuff out
later
boy do I care about
this I don't know what this
is we don't need this OBS buffer either
I don't think we need any of this [ __ ]
honestly any of this at
all overheard at Stanford I heard I
heard a girl one time say like I don't
know my program I just changed the while
loop to an if statement and then it
worked
that's
[Laughter]
[Music]
Stamford nope
that was honestly one of the most
disappointing things to me is you know
you work so hard to get to the college
and it's like well the top 10% are
pretty
good so are you kidding
me I got like 10% of these people to
talk to and most of them are shut in
that never leave their room really
me again you can learn that [ __ ] it's
not hard
you can learn I mean you can still learn
this stuff it just requires being very
uncomfortable for a bit
all right where the [ __ ] does this thing
come
hoct all right so we got to figure this
stupid Hoy [ __ ] out I guess
but I think in the meantime if I just
comment
what this is what
sleep no I get a lot of sleep I've been
coding for a while but I get eight or
nine hours of sleep and I'm going to get
eight or nine hours of sleep mainly back
in Engineers of course Bunch mumbo
jumbo is this spe extendable and modular
yeah that's
wrong that's like the biggest lie they
tell you
how do your eyes handle the
non-contrasted code theme what do you
mean it is plenty
contrasted the reason that the
extendable and modu
modular thing is a lie is because you
never know what ways to make it
extendable in modular up front so you'll
always be wrong so you'll overbuild the
thing every single time which will
prevent you from actually building it in
the way that that you need to once you
figure that out you always just do it in
the simplest damn way possible and go
from there and half the time the
simplest thing just
works very very easily it's actually
incredibly easy for me to build stuff on
top of what I have because I just have
five times less code than you is
basically the idea if I have five times
less code then you it really doesn't
matter what your code looks like it's
still easier for me to add stuff and
change stuff
around I just have less code to deal
with I can't create empty temps are
lovely
oops oh I did that intentionally so I
don't use it very
much I did that intentionally so I don't
use it very much
we're a huge [ __ ] code B
right well it depends I specializing
mediumsized stuff but the thing is
like I might have a 20,000 line project
but I guarantee you if you gave puffer
lib to some Fang Engineers to build
they'd have a 300 L like a 300,000 line
project somehow right so they'd
basically turn the medium project into a
large project and they'd say oh it's so
hard and so complicated we have so much
code yeah you have so much code because
you wrote it
wrong just don't abstract abstraction is
bad stop it I mean seriously give it a
try do it less see if you have a easier
time try it a bit look at some of a code
as well I mean this isn't my code this
is me refactoring
garbage like if you want to see my
actual code okay let me show you
something mediumsized
all right this is a pretty fleshed out
MMO uh runs on the web runs agents on
the web it's pretty cool
here's the
code it's one. h file I think there's
may be like an additional Simplex
Library I include like this that's about
it and if you scroll down here it's very
simple procedural
code everything just makes sense it's
very easy to follow here's some logging
here's the pear and noise gen here's the
flood fill here's cellular automet we
use all these for terrain gen here's
your terrain gen function here's the
entity struct scroll scroll scroll
scroll and
like if I gave you this it would be well
over 10,000 lines and I know because
I've written over 10,000 lines for
something similar neural mmo2 is like
10,000 lines and it's about the same
thing
and it's a thousand times slower than
this give it a try you might be
surprised don't build a factory don't do
that add the different payment
processors when you need the different
payment processors
don't plan for stuff that you know is
that you don't know is going to be a
problem look if you know upfront that
the requirement is we need to support
these three processors then build for
that right you probably don't even need
like you probably literally just if
payment one if payment two if payment
three it's not that
hard you really don't need to overthink
it it's a it's really it's a noob trap
is what it
is what's this can't create empty tensor
how do I find where this thing
is it really is a noob trap I'm telling
you
doesn't matter I just want to see the
robots in the scene dude so all I want
to do is I want to see the robots in the
scene can't create empty tensor
okay I don't call oh I forgot to call
reset hold
on but this is probably going to break
some [ __ ]
dude don't plan for the next 10 years
you're going to be
wrong you're always going to be wrong so
stop trying to plan for it write less
code and then it'll be easier for you to
fix it when you need to fix
it yeah you've been lied to I hate to
tell you like object-oriented
programming is like this weird brain
worm that infects everyone it's like as
soon as you program not in that way you
see oh holy hell there's a whole other
way that you can write code that's way
easier
still yeah I saw a robot I want the
robot to be there
consistently wait can't create empty
tensor is already called hold on
it's in
um it's in reset
somewhere okay there are a couple places
yes there are a couple places where you
need to have some sort of objectoriented
like thing uh usually you want it for
dynamic dispatch it's like if you're
looping over many things of different
types and they all need to have the same
behavior or they all need to have a
specific behavior but the same thing
there are cases where you want that but
the thing is it's vastly overused it
should not it should be a tool for a
specific scenario it's not a programming
Paradigm when you treat it as one it's
very shitty
this can't create empty tensor driving
me
nuts I'm just literally going to do this
and see when it makes an empty
tensor you don't need these things most
of the time because these are things
that are bolted on objectoriented
programming you make it less
oh
what I meant to do great point I don't
know how that I typed the totally wrong
no I don't
um mostly
functions it's not functional that's
another Dogma that's just as
bad I mean procedural is just like you
write your code simple that's it you
don't like you don't have any fancy
ideas that you're trying to
impose just write your simple
code stay away from functional
programming be my
advice it's just it's another
objectoriented programming they replaced
one dog mod with another okay here it is
gym torch rapid sensor tensor
dude
where how do I manage to delete a line
I'm like just tired I don't know how I
manage to do
weird oh it's probably because the
action space sample
huh yeah I bet it's because of that hold
on
still seg FS
really I guess the action space must be
the wrong shape
single action
space how do you figure out the action
space and Isaac gem
what if I comment the
actions can I do
that I just want this to run
appears well it renders for a second at
least
the only place functional kind of makes
a little bit of sense is when you're
working with data
frames like when you're chaining SQL
queries together that's kind
of so it has a use case but it's a NE
use case if you try to use it everywhere
you're just
dumb what do you wait so so what do you
do so what do you actually do I'm
current I'm not pro procedure like I can
write code however this is just
easier and no it's not the only one this
is incredibly common like literally
anybody like the vast majority of lower
level languages are written this way
like a lot of code is written this way
in fact because C doesn't have built-in
objectoriented features so you either
Frankenstein something or you write the
language the way it was intended to be
written the thing is that languages can
actually push you towards writing code a
certain way right so in Python you don't
have structs see if you had a struct
object then you would be more inclined
to write code this way because you could
write functions that just operate on
those strs you don't have structs you
have data classes data classes though
those can have methods too so you get
tempted to add some really what is a
data class but just a class anyways with
some annoying things you just turn it
into a regular class and then you may as
well just add the methods to the class
directly then you may as well just add
some inheritance here and there and then
before you know it your code base
sucks language pushes you towards that
you can write code without that but the
language pushes you towards it C on the
other hand it pushes you towards writing
code the way that I described because
you have strs which are just pieces of
data and then you write functions which
operate on
strs you don't really have the ability
to turn things into objects that take
methods without frankensteining some
weird void star thing which is so
awkward that you don't really try to do
it because it's just kind of
stupid it's just you've been lied to as
all you've just like you've seen too
much code written this one way and it's
like ah this is the way the code is
written but this is not the way the code
is written lots of code is written in
other
ways like I said I get lots of sleep I
wish I could figure out why this thing
opens for just a second and then crashes
cuz like there's the robot it disappears
and then it crashes
does it crash after one step or is there
like a horizon that I'm
missing let's see one 2
like dude you should get sleep just go
to sleep now now it's incredibly
important like I'm going to get eight
or9 hours of sleep I don't have the
schedule I get to sleep whenever the
hell I
want right I'm getting work done so I'm
working
I know how to write code that way it's
just
bad I'll spend more time debugging it
than if I were to write code this way
it'll be less stable it'll have more
bugs and more problems and it'll be
harder to modify because there'll be
more of it I've done this for like 10
years man
it's like you can write passable
objectoriented code but it's always
going to be harder to like understand
than uh than something procedural at
least for like midsize
stuff even for larger stuff to be
honest do you know the amount of
marketing that went into
Java it's one of the big reasons object
oriented took off so much it was a
ridiculously marketed thing for a
programming
language everybody wanted
Java all I'm saying is try it for a bit
you know
see how you like
it this is so confusing as to why
this thing doesn't
work I mean like pie torch is fine pie
torch is like object oriented API is
fine right that's a good example of
something that's like fine
right because it's very horizontal right
it doesn't go
deep right it's just a bunch of
like there's like a like a module and
it's very horizontal there just a bunch
of modules that all have the same API
that's
fine as soon as you start going
deep and a lot of the time the
horizontal doesn't even need to be
horizontal not
necessarily it depends who you talk to
man oh look at all the Bots I see
multiple
Bots
okay and then you
simulate on the second render step you
fail why do you fail on the second
render step is that a thing
gone and then it's say
fults okay so something's going very
wrong
here um I think if I do hold
SW is the
thing
friender well yeah but you're Court like
you shouldn't pay too much attention to
that and honestly they really don't you
take like
um I think the very first intro course
is in Java and then after that
gone all your system courses won't
be okay that's interesting you don't
even have to run simulate and it's still
uh it still
step my systems courses unfortunately
sucked which is why it took me an extra
years to find C I had the worst lecturer
imaginable I built the Facebook life
button but cannot string together three
sentences that make any sense
it's a tough part about being a
professor students
remember I'm just going to I really just
want to see this thing
render here what have what happens if I
just do this
huh surely you can't
psych yeah there you go so this thing
does not seg fault now
does let
see still seg fault no what what are you
even seg faulting
on there's not there's nothing to seg
fault
on there's no code
left I don't think you know he built the
like
button I think he was
okay interesting that you call render
again and uh it
breaks I have no idea that's
uh I got to sleep this going to commit
this up I got 1,000 L of the code down
from
2000ish we'll get it working
tomorrow uh one second and I will say
where you can find some of my stuff
okay so that's online now want to play
with it um all my stuff is open
source right here puffer
AI you can star the GitHub check out the
code here really helps me out star the
GitHub join the Discord we got tons of
people in here building all sorts of
reinforcement learning stuff you don't
need prior RL experience you just need
to know how to write some decent code we
got lots of people that we've trained in
here to build all sorts of fun
environments including many of the ones
that you can demo on the website most of
these are by
contributors we got a Blog here
including a quick start guide for
beginners but also lots of Cutting Edge
stuff we're really pushing the frontiers
of RL here and if you want more RL
content you can follow me on X I go live
here as well but there are also some
articles you can't find anywhere
else so thanks folks and I will be back
streaming pretty much as soon as I wake
up